الماده
الاولى يولد جميع الناس احرارا ومتساوين
في الكرامه والحقوق وهم قد وهبوا العقل
والوجدان وعليهم ان يعاملوا بعضهم بعضا
بروح
الاخاء الماده
الثانيه لكل انسان حق التمتع بجميع الحقوق
والحريات الم في هذا الاعلام دون ما تمييز
من اي نوع ولا سما التمييز بسبب العنصر او
اللون او الجنس او اللغه او الدين او
الراي سياسيا وغير سياسي او الاصل الوطني
او الاجتماعي او الثروه او المولد او اي
وضع اخر وفضلا عن ذلك لا يجوز التمييز على
اساس الوضع السياسي او القانوني او الدولي
للبلد او الاقليم الذي ينتمي اليه الشخص
سواء اكان مستقلا او موضوعا تحت الوصايه
او غير متمتع بالحكم الذاتي ام خاضعا لاي
قيد اخر على
سيادته الماده
الثالثه لكل فرد الحق في الحياه والحريه
وفي الامان على
شخصه الماده
الرابعه
لا يجوز استرقاق احد او
استعباده ويحضر الرق والاتجار بالرقيق
بجميع
[موسيقى]
صورهما الماده
الخامسه لا يجوز اخضاع احد للتعذيب ولا
للمعامله او العقوبه القاسيه او اللا
انسانيه او الحاطه
بالكرامه الماده
السادسه
لكل انسان في كل مكان الحق بان يعترف له
بالشخصيه
القانونيه الماده
السابعه الناس جميعا سواء امام القانون
وهم يتساوون في حق التمتع بحمايه القانون
دون ما تمييز كما يتساوون في حق التمتع
بالحمايه من اي تمييز ينتهك هذا الاعلام
ومن اي تحريض على مثل هذا
[موسيقى]
التمييز الماده
الثامنه لكل شخص حق اللجوء الى المحاكم
الوطنيه المختصه ل انصافه الفعلي من ايه
اعمال تنتهك الحقوق الاساسيه التي يمنحها
اياه الدستور او
[موسيقى]
القانون الماده
التاسعه لا يجوز اعتقال اي انسان او حجزه
او نفيه
تعسفا الماده
العاشره لكل انسان على قدم المساواه
التامه مع الاخرين الحق في ان تنظر قضيته
محكمه مستقله ومحاي نظرا منصفا
وعلنيا للفصل في حقوقه
والتزاماته وفي ايه تهمه جزائيه توجه
اليه الماده الحاد
عش كل شخص متهم بجريمه يعتبر بريئا الى ان
يثبت ارتكابه لها قانونا في محاكمه علنيه
تكون قد وفرت لها جميع الضمانات اللازمه
للدفاع عن نفسه لا يدان اي شخص بجريمه
بسبب اي عمل او امتناع عن عمل لم يكن في
حينه يشكل جرما بمقتضى القانون الوطني او
الدولي كما لا توقع عليه ايه عقوبه اشد من
تلك التي كانت ساريه في الوقت الذي ارتكب
فيه الفعل
الجرمي الماده
الثانيه لا يجوز تعريض احد لتدخل تعسفي في
حياته الخاصه او في شؤون اسرته او مسكنه
او مراسلاته ولا لحما
تمس شرفه وسمعته ولكل شخص حق في ان يحميه
القانون من مثل ذلك التدخل او تلك
الحملات الماده الث
ع لكل فرد حق في حريه
التنقل وفي اختيار محل اقامته داخل حدود
الدوله لكل فرد حق في مغادره اي بلد بما
في ذلك بلده وفي العوده الى
بلده الماده ال 14
عش لكل فرد حق في التماس ملجا في بلدان
اخرى والتمتع به خلاصا من
الاضطهاد لا يمكن التذرع بهذا الحق اذا
كانت هناك ملاحقه ناشئه بالفعل عن جريمه
غير سياسيه او اعمال تناقض مقاصد الامم
المتحده
ومبادئها الماده الخ
ع لكل فرد حق التمتع بجنسيه
ما لا يجوز تعسفا حرمان اي شخص من جنسيته
ولا من حقه في تغيير
جنسيته الماده
الساب لكل فرد حق في التملك بمفرده او
بالاشتراك مع
غيره لا يجوز تجريد احد من ملكه
تعسفا الماده
التا لكل شخص حق التمتع بحريه الراي
والتعبير ويشمل هذا الحق حريته في اعتناق
الاراء دون مضايقه وفي التماس الانباء
والافكار وتلقيها ونقلها الى
بايه وسيله ودون ما اعتبار
للحدود الماده
العشر لكل شخص حق في حريه الاشتراك في
الاجتماعات والجمعيات
السلميه لا يجوز ارغام احد على الانتماء
الى جمعيه
ما الماده
الحاديه لكل شخص حق الماركه في اداره
الشؤون العامه لبلده اما مباشره واما
بواسطه ممثلين يختارون في
حريه لكل شخص بالتساوي مع الاخرين حق تقلد
الوظائف العامه في بلده اراده الشعب هي
مناط سلطه الحكم ويجب ان تتجلى هذه
الاراده من خلال انتخابات نزيهه تجري
دوريا بالاقتراع العام وعلى قدم المساواه
بين الناخبين وبالصو السري او باجراء
مكافئ من حيث ضمان حريه
[موسيقى]
التصويت الماده
الثانيه لكل شخص بوصفه عضوا في المجتمع حق
في الضمان الاجتماعي ومن حقه ان توفر له
من خلال المجهود القومي والتعاون الدولي
وبما يتفق مع هيكل كل دوله ومواردها
الحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والثقافيه
التي لاغنى عنها لكرامته
ولتناول الماده
الثال لكل شخص حق العمل وفي حريه اختيار
عمله وفي شروط عمل عادله ومرضيه وفي
الحمايه من البطاله لجميع الا دون اي
تمييز الحق في اجر متساو على العمل
المتساوي لكل فرد يعمل حق في مكافاه عادله
ومرضيه تكفل له ولاسرته عيشه لائقه
بالكرامه البشريه وتستكمل عند الاقتضاء
بوسائل اخرى للحمايه
الاجتماعيه لكل شخص حق انشاء النقابات مع
اخرين والانضمام اليها من اجل حما
مصالحه الماده
العه لكل شخص حق في الراحه واوقات الفراغ
وخصوصا في تحديد معقول لساعات العمل وفي
اجازات دوريه
[موسيقى]
ماجوره الماده
الساسه لكل شخص حق في التعليم
ويجب ان يوفر التعليم مجانا على الاقل في
مرحلتيه الابتدائيه والاساسيه ويكون
التعليم الابتدائي
الزاميا ويكون التعليم الفني والمهني
متاحا للعموم ويكون التعليم العالي متاحا
للجميع تبعا
لكفاءتهم يجب ان يستهدف التعليم التنميه
الكامله لشخصيه الانسان وتعزيز احترام
حقوق الانسان والحريات
الاساسيه كما يجب ان يعزز التفاهم
والتسامح والصداقه بين جميع الامم وجميع
الفئات العنصريه او الدينيه وان يؤيد
الانشطه التي تطلع بها الامم المتحده لحفظ
السلام للاباء على سبيل الاولويه حق
اختيار نوع التعليم الذي يعطى
لاولادهم الماده
السابعه
لكل شخص حق المشاركه الحره في حياه
المجتمع الثقافيه وفي الاستمتاع بالفنون
والاسهام في التقدم العلمي وفي الفوائد
التي تنجم عنه لكل شخص حق في حمايه
المصالح المعنويه والماديه المترتبه على
اي انتاج علمي او ادبي او فني من
[موسيقى]
صنغ الده الثام
والش لكل فرد حق التمتع بنظام اجتماعي
ودولي يمكن ان تتحقق في ظله الحقوق
والحريات المنصوص عليها في هذا الاعلان
تحققا
تاما الماده
ال9 على كل فرد واجبات ازاء الجماعه التي
فيها وحدها يمكن ان تنمو شخصيته النمو
الحر الكامل لا يخضع اي فرد في ممارسه
حقوقه وحرياته الا للقيود التي يقررها
القانون مستهدفا منها حصرا ضمان الاعتراف
الواجب بحقوق وحريات الاخرين واحترامها
والوفاء بالعادل من مقتضيات الفضيله
والنظام العام ورفاه الجميع في مجتمع
ديمقراطي لا يجوز في اي حال ان تمارس هذه
الحقوق على نحو يناقض مقاصد الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
ومبادئها